- I just had an incredible
eCommerce meeting here
on a Saturday, as you guys know,
I don't usually work on Saturday,
but I'm here for All-Star
Weekend in Los Angeles.
The weather is fuckin' phenomenal.
'Bout to go to Baron Davis' event,
I think I'm going to rip it up pretty good
for the NBA players.
And just living the dream,
puttin' the pieces together,
eCommerce, selling stuff, it's good.
It's fucking good.
- [Boy] Vlog?
- What's that?
I do.
- What's your name?
- Gary.
- Oh, you're Gary Vee?
- I am.
- Whoa, nice, that's sick,
can I make your vlog?
- Yeah, of course, what's your name?
- Sruly.
Sruly what are you into?
- Sneakers.
- You flip 'em?
- Yeah.
- My guy.
What's the best flip you've had?
- Well I'm actually pretty new, yeah.
- So, do you have a flip yet or not yet?
- Nah, but.
- So you're an aspiring
flipper, not a flipper.
There's a big difference
between doing and aspiring to,
he doesn't flip kicks, he aspires to.
So, Sruly, get your shit together.
(drum and bass riff)
- Can I take a photo of you?
- Can you take a photo
with my wife over here.
- Actually, you know what,
I'm going to take you.
- So, what, are you speaking today?
- Yeah, but I have no idea what or how,
or about what, but I'm about to find out.
- What's going on, my guy?
- What's happenin'.
- Thanks for the invite.
You ready drink?
- Ready to sip with a sip.
- A little sippy-sip?
- Here, yeah (talking under crowd noise).
- This is the way I do it.
Just go right through it.
Best trick in the game.
- How ya doin', man, you alright?
- I'm really good, my man, real pleasure.
Guy, good to see you
again, man, how are you?
- Good.
- You feelin' good?
What's up, man, how are you?
- Nice to meet you.
- Real pleasure, my man, how are things?
- How you doin'?
- Congratulations, my guy.
- Nice to meet you.
- Fuckin' what's up, man, congratulations.
- I appreciate that.
- That was amazing.
- Everything's good, ya ya ya.
- Crazy feeling?
- Yes, it's amazing.
- Climbing that mountain.
- Yeah, it was a lot of work, but I mean,
the roller coaster, everything,
but we finished on top, so.
- Ya man, it's a real pleasure.
- Thank you.
- It's been really fun, getting
to know you family and crew.
- Ya, this is my team.
- I facetimed with your
Mom, which is a lot of fun.
- Oh, you did?.
- She's lovely.
- Ya, she loves you.
- Thank you, thank you.
- He loves you too.
- I love him back, I just
told him he smelled great.
Fuckin' crazy, man.
It's just, you know, like, as a fan,
I've been trying to win a ring since 82.
(laughing)
This guy gets a quick little trade
and he picks one up quick.
- Luck of the draw, man.
- Ya man, that worked out nice.
Ya, but you know what, luck
of the draw, that part,
but a whole lot of fuckin'
hard work, you know?
- Right.
- I wish people understood
how hard pit-athletes work.
- They don't understand it.
- They don't get it.
- They think they're
just so overpaid, like.
- It's just about money.
- Ya man, it takes so much.
You guys gettin' work in this week?
- Yeah.
- There's a lot going on.
All-Star in LA.
- It's different.
- Different.
- How are you?
- Always good, huge fan,
worked with this on his social digital,
want to get him on your
podcast eventually,
after the season's over.
Who do I talk to?
- Me.
So good to see you.
Favorite guy from Planet of the Apps.
(laughing)
Yo, what up, Snapchat?
DRock, DRock motivated me, talkin' about,
what up, baby, tell him, shh.
I like the shh so much.
(friendly chattering)
Yo yo yo, what up, Facebook?
About to speak at this conference,
Baron Davis' conference,
but more importantly, excited to come on
and talk to you guys about
my new First In Line thing.
It is very very very simple.
It is basically a messenger
and text situation,
where I'm gonna put out
jabs and right hooks.
It's gonna be opportunities
to get free shit.
I've already got two companies
that are hitting me up with some stuff.
Where the first 500 people
that fill out the form,
boom, get it, free stuff.
Tons of stuff is being thrown at me
I don't need it, or want it,
but I want to share it with my community,
so that's what you're going to see
from First In Line, the opportunity
to buy First In Line stuff like,
these limited edition K-Swiss,
there's only 150 pairs.
And so, people from First In Line
are going to be able to get that first.
And then, next time I
get a Facebook beanie,
I'm going to ask for 50 of them,
boom, put 'em out on First In Line,
and you got 'em.
Somebody want a one hour class with DRock,
to learn how it's done,
boom, First In Line.
- [DRock] One hour.
- One hour, fuckin' DRock.
You gonna give it too them DRock?
- Ya, of course.
- Good, boom.
So that's what's up,
that's how we're doin' it.
First In Line, First
In Line, First In Line.
(friendly chattering and laughing)
- I'm Tosca Musk, I worked on Tiki Bar TV.
I produced Tiki Bar TV
way back in the day.
- No kiddin', yeah, oh my God,
that's some old school stuff.
- Early days.
- That's amazing, how are you?
- Good, how are you doin'?
- Oh God, that just
brought back such a flood
of good memories.
There was literally five vlogs.
- Yeah.
- There was like five video shows.
- And we were one of them.
- You sure were.
- And I remember I met you at,
I think it was at South by Southwest,
that first time, when Kevin Rose
sent out that tweet, to
say let's have a party
at this bar, and all of us
showed up there randomly.
- It was the best, those were some days.
- Back in the early days,
when nobody else was on Twitter.
- When you could get
5000 people to show up
with one tweet.
Those secret wine parties
that I was throwing back then
were so fun.
Ah, Tiki Bar TV, and the
guy with the hat, right?
- Yeah, Johnny Johnny.
- Johnny Johnny.
- I gotta get key-bo movin' too.
- Are those yours, are those your jogs?
- Look at this.
- Those are the K-Swiss'?
Oh, you're a fuck-head, look at you.
- This is a limited
edition that I'm dropping
next Wednesday.
Don't tell 'em five-time, baby!
- Ooh!
- Five time!
- Put a five up, put a five up.
- Five time.
- Like, I'm sure there's somebody in here
that think they can hoop better than me.
(laughing)
Even though those are lies.
- You gonna get a good spot?
- [Male Off-Scree] Yeah.
- I feel like I'm gonna.
To answer your question, my
number one objective right now,
in general, is to make good traits alpha.
- Oh.
- So, what I'm real
passionate about right now
is making empathy and gratitude
and kindness cool as fuck.
(woman talking off stage)
- What, you like that?
- That's the black term for that.
- I know what it is.
(laughing)
- My God, what up, baby?
- How you doin', man.
- Good to see you, how are you?
- Good to see you too.
How's the weekend going?
- Real good.
- Ya ya, straight
forward, appreciate that.
- Thank you.
- You're what we need though,
- I'm tryin'.
- You got that social impact.
- Truth.
- [Gary] There's nobody that
makes it in to the league
without sacrificing things,
and I think successful
entrepreneurs is the lead.
There's nobody who's hit it,
who did it, who got lucky.
People love lucky, people love excuses,
you're in control of your shit.
The internet's changed everything.
Every excuse coming out of your mouth,
the answer is d-am, because the internet
has changed everything.
We haven't calibrated how big it is.
There's no middle man, there's no system,
there's no old white dude stopping you.
Go do your thing.
This internet thing is real as fuck,
and so for me, I just think
it's the greatest time
to be alive, and if you're not winning,
during this era of internet at scale,
and fuckin' nine straight
years of economic growth,
then you suck.
(friendly chattering and beat music)
How many people under
30, raise your hands,
right, right, tons of.
So one of the things I hate
is people shit on millennials,
they're the same, everything's the same.
You knew lazy people, you
knew hard-working people.
Millennials have so many advantages,
under 30 has so many advantages.
Actually the only
disadvantage I think they have
is they haven't been
punched in the mouth yet.
They haven't lived through 2008, or 2001.
There's a lot of people in here over 40
who are rich on paper,
or made it in 2001, 2006,
and then the economy got fucked, right?
It's real cool when you're
an Instagram influencer
and making $100,000 in sponsorship deals,
until the world melts and
those brands aren't paying.
Ya so, here we are.
Listen to me, I'm going crazy right now,
and Twitter probably posted like 17 posts,
it's the same thing, my face red,
and all it says is, and question mark.
The level of excuses, you
know, my parents did this,
I grew up there, their
stuff sucks, mine's better,
debt, my boss fuckin' sucks
and he's suppressing me.
The answer to everything is, and ?
Like what are you gonna do about it?
And, what the fuck are you
gonna do about it, right?
Sitting and complaining
does jack fuckin' shit.
And so no matter what you tell me,
you email me, you dm me,
you spill everything.
I got compassion, I got empathy,
but after I absorb that,
and show you that I care, the
answer is always going to be,
and ?
What the fuck are we gonna do about it.
Way-on, just made a piece of cut-cut.
It's so true.
Well, I got a ticket for you.
Ya, you're comin' in.
So my big fear right now is like,
look, be smart, be thoughtful,
like build something
that you can control.
Like, everybody cryin' about Instagram
and Facebook's algorithm.
It was free, you built on it for free,
so they changed it because
the attention of that user
is everything, that's what matters,
and so they're gonna do
it, what's right for them,
and so if you're crying that
your organic reach dropped,
then fuckin' work,
start a fuckin' podcast,
fuckin' start a newsletter, do something
instead of crying that you got 7,000 likes
instead of 11,000, you fuckin' loser.
(laughing)
It's true!
(drum and bass beats)